this is what i do when i get off the
youtube
oh my gosh are you
feeling uh a slight cough at all no
that's how you know it's working and to
fuzz and [ __ ] in your neighborhood
in your neighborhood in your
neighborhood
so we're going to talk about the cube
center okay
however it's not really just about
groups oh my gosh of course
let's go to check what is a good way to
refute the assertion that public
services
are socialism what is the legitimate
purview of government
it really comes down to keeping the
people safe from
internal and external threats that
includes the military police the
national guard
and making sure that everyone is playing
by the rules outside of that
it really isn't the government's job to
step in our way ultimately
youtube wants to be tv which means that
youtubers will now have to live under
the standards
that tv people do and unless you're
making fun of the president
every single night including for things
like his physical appearance
we do that here but yeah yeah yeah that
hair goes like this
it's
subject for like
it must be hard to breathe in that thing
no this is actually by the way we have
rand paul on the show today we'll be
talking about the new release of cuties
as well as what democrats plan to do
hint white house each
if uh donald trump wins re-election so
my question to you is what do you expect
the left to do if you win but yeah this
is an actual spit hood we got
it from a police officer okay oh that's
nice this is the actual
spin and look look look i can drink from
my cup
well that's nice not real i don't worry
if anything my worries and it might not
actually work look watch this
my desk is covered in my spit hood well
that's that's true i think you would
have
actually spit hood remnants it's like
it's from a woman's negligee
yeah yeah we can see your face very
clearly through the hood i think you
would actually have to try to suffocate
you
know
women would be given magazines they
convince women like sometimes it's
sexier if you wear a little bit of
something and so it's like i put on
something that is see-through and
nothing
sheer that's this i can't believe that
anyone would complain about
if i robbed a bank in this yeah they'd
be like do you know did you get a look
at him oh yeah it was stephen
that's right
oh my gosh um incredible we have a lot
to get to uh here by the way my half age
and larry bill richmond
you here uh i was a little nervous about
spit hood uh quarter black garrett audio
wade g morgan junior gerald has a little
one that he's doing very well don't
care yes you do you love him
we'll be talking about cuties today and
i was struggling with this there's a lot
to get
oh my god also all of the democrats from
major cities who have
uh opted to support the defunding of
police while upping their own security
to the tune
of many millions of dollars uh do we oh
we don't have
do we not have cnn this morning can
someone get it up uh get it going
no i didn't want to throw up today well
we know what they're covering that's for
sure but first before we move on
um trevor noah has something to say
about gender-revealed parties
celebrating a baby's genitalia is
starting to feel very outdated
like given everything we're learning
about gender gender reveal parties
should only happen when the child is old
enough to know their actual gender
and to pitch in some cash for the fire
damage so so like six months down the
line when they hit the casting call for
cuties
yeah or the latest vox video about
estrogen about uh testosterone blockers
oh they actually
we shouldn't have a gender revealed
party and by the way this is the same
guy i just wanted to hit on this because
it will tie back to cuties this is the
guy who accuses
everyone in this room of being
anti-science
why does the news keep bringing on
non-scientists
to argue against science i mean cnn pays
rick santorum
to come on and talk that sh this woman's
group has gotten
funding from oil companies so why is the
news heavyweight
science and any normal president pretend
that the vaccine will be released based
on science but trump doesn't even
pretend
guys got the worst poker face in the
world which
that's a good point because that's with
an applause sign yeah
either either okay there's one of two
scenarios with trevor noah's show
either every one of the kind of people
who smoke on a plane and ignore the sign
and don't wear their seatbelt the entire
audience was filled to the brim with
them or
trevor no it's not funny i leave it up
to you
uh b option b no no no no no they were
all asleep stephen
yes he couldn't make it the shot callers
weren't going
because he's not funny though so it does
go back to option b uh by the way please
do consider joining uh mug club at
loudouncredit.com
slash michael that's what it allows us
to do any of these programs 69 dollars
for students veterans active military
and we will have a live stream on
tuesday of the entire
president trump town hall of course you
can also listen on android uh
and apple uh and listen for the secret
hidden word that we put in the
audio exclusive podcast oh my god come
back here comment it below and you might
get a lot of gerald's hair let's see
what they're showing on scene very
likely let's check it out right now
there's no reason for americans to to
panic this is something that
uh is a low risk we think in the us but
president trump from the day he took
office made
protecting americans and keeping them
safe whether it's from terrorists or
criminal organizations or from viruses
like the new
uh novel coronavirus uh we're gonna get
to this because this is what everyone is
talking about
and the thing that actually reg and i
were talking about this and he made a
great point if woodward believed that
donald trump was lying to the american
public
it would whatever happened to the ethics
in journalism right the aaron brock
which is the world i know she wasn't a
journalist she was abroad with a push-up
bra something with tap water but the
point is
in films they always show up i must tell
the people
right yeah i am the people's journalist
and in this case
uh if woodward actually believed that
donald trump was lying to the american
public it would have been his
journalistic duty to tell somebody
he didn't think that no one thinks that
he had to wait till he could sell the
book off of it stephen come on
um and of course listen uh tomorrow is
um
the obvious the 19th anniversary of 9
11. and listen uh we've talked about
there are a lot of people who've been
born after who are about to go into
college who don't really know what that
was like
right and uh it shaped all of our
experiences so uh here at ladder with
crowd of course we
want to uh to honor and remember those
and actually remember what it was like
that day
um when it happened which we should have
seen
yeah then oh yeah the media bias
and it was it was a little bit
apprehensive about bringing up 911 at
all because you get the conspiracy
theorists you do you say what about
tower seven listen tower seven i get it
wouldn't it wouldn't have come down if
the firefighters could have got there it
had blm not been blocking the police
line
always always with the blocks they
couldn't get there
it's just terrible jeez spit hood and 9
11 jokes
that's how we start the show that's how
we start the show and it's not a 911
joke it's a media
is a horrible cesspool of filth and
sadness right it really is
the media's always been a horrible trash
heap it's just that now with new media
or really as it's known to people under
the age of 25
media yeah uh it just doesn't work
anymore no
it's putting things in context it's
reasonable okay so this is my question
what do you think that the the left
plans to do uh if and when donald trump
wins the election
uh re-election so i want to get into
this because it's it is a little bit
nutty when you see and rand paul will be
coming after this up after this we'll be
talking about security yeah the left
talking about how this will be an unjust
election how
uh donald trump wants to erode the trust
in american institutions and by the way
you shouldn't trust american
institutions namely the ones that donald
trump supports which is how we've held
our elections forever
yeah and then they say hey we've also
run numbers to see if donald trump wins
and how the left reacts it's not pretty
and then they call you trumpkins and say
trumpkins have a conspiracy that there's
gonna be violent
unrest if donald trump i'm talking to
you daily beast i don't know how
i don't know what your application i
assume
that it needs to include in the byline
filthy prick
you have to check that box i have yet to
read an article
of any value at the daily beast within
the last
three years and you've been reading it
every day all made my
life a worse place
for having read them so uh let's go
through the list here because this is
the narrative right donald trump wants
to erode trust in american institutions
hey
i say i believe that it's the left who
wants to do that uh case number one
uh the man whose head uh seemingly
continues to grow into the shape of the
emoji eggplant mark zuckerberg on the
election
one of the things that i think we it's
an eggplant ahead
of other media really is preparing
um the american people that um there's
nothing illegitimate about
this election taking additional days or
even weeks
to make sure that all the votes are
counted in fact that might be important
to make sure that this is a legitimate
um
and fair election so we're going to do
a a bunch of different messaging around
that just to make sure that people know
that that's normal so if one of the
it's not normal in any of the races it's
incredibly rare before there's
um a consensus result then
we're going to add some informational
context to that post directly saying
that
um that there there's no consensus
result yet
ah i'm gonna fact check it with your
southern poverty law center buddies
we want people to know that if this
election tends to be if it appears to be
an outlier to every other american
election
by and large due to our underhanded
methods we want them to know that that's
normal
it's not nope it's not normal and you're
an [ __ ]
[ __ ] it is remarkable to me donald
trump runs to a road trip that's an
american institutions by the way the way
that you've seen elections and watched
election results come in
for your entire lives and your parents
lives and your grant
um it's normal to not do that
we're going to do the opposite it's like
yeah you know what the super bowl will
be normal if instead they come out with
baseball bats strip naked and
saying clan clan clang went to trolley
as they run down the field well that's
not normal well
up to you what is normal
it's not a lecture you told me coverage
it's election month
coverage i think now so we have to have
more cnn live streams is that right
but this is not here's the thing this
comes from this is why this is so
important to me
to me i should say that's the most
powerful that's
that's someone more powerful than caesar
okay
facebook alphabet youtube you know all
too well off
youtube google and twitter they have
more power than most nations could have
ever dreamed and they are echoing
exactly what you see in here
from the top how do i mean top number
one
and number two presidential choices
candidates from the dnc hillary clinton
here's what she had to say if donald
trump wins you know joe biden should not
concede
under any circumstances because
i think this is going to be wow and
eventually i do believe he will win if
we don't give
an inch drop i'm sorry he should not
concede under any circumstances
well what if he loses yeah
well hold on she she actually revealed
her hand there she said
we i think if we drag basically drag
this process out long enough eventually
he will win eventually we'll have enough
time to
rig or throw out trump's votes or what
eventually what
are things gonna change what's the point
with more time it cheats yeah
exactly the election there's no place
that's what she plans to do it and but
when she said this by the way i guess
that's i guess it's par for the course
this is the lady who didn't come out to
deliver her concession speech and
everyone said
thank the lord above we didn't put her
in office could you imagine
thank the lord we didn't put her in
office before she went through menopause
could you imagine that four to seven
days each month
this lady wouldn't even show up to face
the music and give a concession
session speech and before that it was a
tired old trope like oh you don't want
to see me president because we're
missing and everyone said you really
think that women listed all the stuff
that they do
and then the one presidential female
candidate didn't come out and do what
every other male had done which is eat
[ __ ] and take your loss
what she did was sit backstage and cry
she cried no she said how
how is it possible it can't be happening
this whole world is destroyed
they went really quick from wearing it
as a badge like you throw like a girl
you hit like a girl you cry like a girl
and their whole camera was yes
i am a girl i am proud of it because we
are strong and then she lost
which i'm also i was very confused
because i didn't think she was capable
of actual emotions
sure yeah you know it's actually
surprising you know what you're hearing
right now is the spin on both of those
conversations that's coming from the
left or the excuses if you will right
the the spokes people that are coming
out
they're all saying no no you know look
at bush v gore you know it took some
time to figure it out
you know there may be some circumstances
but just like you said gerald it's a
very rare time and what gives me
pauses it's early september and you're
saying now you're
already kind of setting the stage for
there to be this period of days or weeks
according to zuckerberg
that it would take to actually even
determine but what are you saying and
that's what i'm most concerned about
is them setting the stage for at the end
to start letting the hijinks begin i'm
not
i think right i think the biggest
problem is we don't know what the high
jinks will be right yeah um but
they're more about setting it all it
could be anything but when you do away
with the entire
standardized voting system when they say
donald trump's trying to steal the
election then donald trump says they're
trying to steal the election
this is where you have to use put on
your rationalization cap hopefully it's
thicker than the spit hood
and you say hold on a second who is
trying to pull a fast one on me the one
who is trying to ensure that elections
are held
fair and free the way they always have
been with a system of checks and
balances where we do know that there's
a certain baseline level of transparency
that's expected or the ones who want to
try something completely
new a process shrouded in mystery and
tell us that the results could uh
come in at some point in the indefinite
future use
your thinking cap who is trying to pull
the spit hood over your eyes
and what's uh what this is though is
it's a very clear admission
that they are now engaging in a process
they are asking states and they are
encouraging states to engage in a
process
that will necessarily have to unlike
almost
every other election we've ever had and
a very important election
take longer be more complex and thus
more fraught with peril
the entire time they have said over and
over again there won't be any problem if
we just at the last minute switch to an
entirely different method of voting
yeah fill out anything and now they're
saying i know we said it was going to be
a problem but
actually getting a correct and timely
result
is not at really it's really not
actually now they're the money pit
construction workers about two weeks
what are we gonna get those results for
the national election
two weeks it's been nine weeks now two
weeks two more
two weeks he says mr eggplant head well
i think we need to go back to trevor
noah
we need the scientists we need the
science we need science to tell us
whether it's safe
we already have that faucet said it's
safe i thought she did say it was
we're not anti-scientists also nancy
pelosi said it was safe when she went
into a
particle uh vortex that was the air
dryer
and the people the people who are were
for three years saying that trump
stole the election are stealing the
election in front of your eyes yes yeah
so these are the same people they have
no standard yeah
it's just like listen when fight people
go into fights if you look at any
fighters and we've had them on the show
i asked remember daniel cormier was on
the show and he was known to have had a
broken hand yeah
and i asked him i said no you know what
i feel good i don't know if you guys
remember off air he was like
i'm still actually kind of recovered
because they don't want to
a reveal their weakness to their
opponent but more importantly they don't
want to have an excuse people of honor
right now this is like
a fighter walking into the cage going ah
you know what i'm going to do my best
don't expect a lot from me i pulled a
hammy doing shuttle runs on the back
yeah it's like no no no no no joe biden
said you have dementia i'm pretty sure
it's the cold hammy
well no we don't believe you you're
making up an excuse right now because
you're attempting to
lie if we want to eliminate the
possibility of lies let's use the system
that we've always used and the
scientific experts have said is
perfectly safe
yeah and it's even worse than that
they're not even just trying to cover up
for maybe abide in loss
and and the weakness of their candidate
they're trying to say no matter what
happens
the only reason that donald trump could
possibly win re-election is
fraud the only reason is because he
stole the election and now we have to
have an uprising to take it back donald
trump is a threat to america right
that's exactly what they're trying to
tell you what's a threat to america
can i also just remember what would you
do and i really want to get to cuties
senators again no i'm kidding here's the
thing who's the party that has been
saying over and over again you should
just accept the results except the
results accept the results never do
anything bad and now they're saying
oh well if we don't like the results
let's just overturn the government right
yeah that's exactly what the senate so
this is an article from washington post
they run an op-ed by a member of the
transition integrity project
first i thought it was you know no no
it's a totally different thing
it's their titles don't mean what they
say what they mean
integrity means [ __ ] so transition
integrity project this was an op-ed by
them at the washington post uh so they
kind of legitimized this person sort of
like you know
like vice with the the portland shooter
um
this person wrote a landslide for joe
biden resulted in a relatively order
transfer of power
every other scenario we looked at
involved street
level violence and political crises you
mean more of it
yeah from one side
why and why why would it be that a
a landslide win for biden but not a
landslide win for trump
let's eliminate the people the middle
right there let's eliminate the median
let's
eliminate that concrete girder that uh
johnny boyd drove me into and went to go
to the aids walker you know
let's eliminate that and people go well
you know what maybe it could have gone
either way but they're saying
landslides so a landslide for donald
trump my right your left
means that there uh there will be unrest
according to this street level
street level violence but a landslide
for biden won't
what does that say about the supporters
of the losing party
when combined keep in mind in tandem
with the previous losing party instead
of showing up and delivering a
concession speech
sat and cried in the room like a [ __ ]
now i'm not supposed to say that because
she's a woman but you would say it about
any guy yeah
it's the prejudice of soft expectations
because we didn't expect you to cry like
a [ __ ]
i really think that's what's gonna
happen yeah i think it's just gonna be a
lot of crying that's it that's that's
again the most likely most prevalent
result that will happen in the event of
a trumpet by the way we get a lot of
people crying
who are subscribed to us because they
don't hit the notification oh
yeah 10 a.m uh monday through thursdays
when we do the show but hit the
notification bell
about all of the all of the live streams
yeah 10 a.m
and uh next tuesday night we'll be doing
the trump town hall live oh
yeah here's another one there's already
a network of left-wing organizations
making plans for
this is the quote from daily beast
occupy
[ __ ] hold space and shut things down not
just on election day but for weeks
and this is what really bothers me
because people will say we're being
conspiratorial right here
like oh this is one of those qa non quan
things
no you know what hold on a second let's
do a side by side where daley beast
wrote this article okay they said that
we should expect
violence not on election day but for
weeks let's bring up this side-by-side
overlap if you can get it
and then yesterday writing trumpkins are
losing their mind over occupy wall
street's
faux plans for a white house siege can
you believe these trump supporters
believe there will be violent unrest or
a seat you
you told me there was going to be
violent unrest hold on a second i want
to make sure i get uh
occupy [ __ ] hold space shut things down
not just an election day for weeks so
you it's not that i'm a trumpkin
it's uh my mistake was trusting you
daily no stephen you're misinterpreting
it that is what they're not calling a
correction
ah they were an error sort of covered up
they're like these trumpet trumpkins
i can't believe they believed us well
it's gonna be his fault no matter what
if he wins it's his fault for winning
and so we have to go and steal the
the country back if he loses then we're
gonna or if it's even close like he said
it's gonna be
a problem we're gonna have street level
violence even if biden wins narrowly
like
who's gonna be violent at that point
well yeah and you remember all the
violent up uh uprising when obama won
and oh eight
oh yeah yeah i remember that yeah
people showed up and left the places
cleaner than they found it yeah those
guys yeah
and used pokey sticks to pick up trash
like ex-cons no media
said they're stabbing people of color
they were sticks yes there's video
evidence of it they shouted the n-word
the media called poc's trash
you're amongst them i'm about to be
slightly frustrated
by that they don't accept you do the
club speaking of
slightly frustrated look at jake
dapper's hairdo it's like he said give
me the willard
uh and right now they're talking about
donald trump
oh my god concealing the coronavirus
threat it's almost
criminal okay let's get to that yes
thank you
um the big story is of course everyone
is trying to say that donald trump said
lied to the public right now this comes
from the uh woodward interview that
donald trump gave with his journalists
too by the way
i was impressed because this guy has
been very unfair to donald trump in the
past yeah so i was surprised that he
gave him more information
um the media confronted and we'll show
the full clip in context but first you
should see what the media is doing and
that they confronted kayleigh mecca
mac i don't know she used to book the
show huckabee when i was there she was
very nice
such a young lady the media attacking
her over donald trump's as you see this
is the news right now criminal activity
did president trump intentionally
mislead the american people about the
threat of covet a pandemic that's a
professional sweater across the lives of
nearly 200 000 americans
absolutely not um this president at a
time when you're facing insurmountable
challenges it's important to express
confidence it's
important to express calm please play it
down it's playing it down is that is
that expressing calm
it seems dishonest can you read the rest
of the clone that's how much they put in
is it
plunging neckline please please
but you know what come on let's just
she's this plunging neckline
as a reporter and then kelly mcillen has
instead of that a shirt
and a cross good versus evil contrast
it's just one of those things like why
would you uh look at a woman and uh
think of uh why would you romanticize
her because i see tits
yeah they're on that's what they want
you to see
uh here is the there was a quote and
they edited it out of context
donald trump say play it down not the
most artful use of language
but let's listen to the clip in context
i wanted to uh i wanted to always play
it down
i still like playing it down yes because
i don't want to create a panic
now keep in mind he wasn't saying that
it didn't exist
playing it down means i don't want
people to panic uh while he was banning
travel
yeah from china he had already taken
actions but he was playing
he should have said you know what listen
i didn't want to blow it out of
proportion
that's clearly what he's saying if you
look at in totality at this point of
this interview where he's saying he's
still playing it down he had taken many
actions
to prevent the spread of the crime
exactly and so they're trying to hang
him on his words they're like oh he knew
that it was deadly and there's some
other stuff
don't say that because then people take
your quote out of context right they're
trying to hang down with trump on his
own
so they're trying to hang him on and out
of context well that's i was that's what
i was getting to
right they're trying to they're trying
to hang him on something that actually
doesn't exist
they're saying that that means that he
was lying to the american public he knew
that this was the bubonic plague and he
said everything's fine go about your
daily lives that's not what he said
could you say and that's all yeah
exactly and that's not what he did
he actually took action so they're
they're divorcing his words and his
actions over here and saying the words
sound bad to us even though they're not
and his actions we don't want to take a
look at those because those were
actually proactive
by the way woodward could not have
believed that he was lying to the
american public because it would have
been his duty to release it
yeah and said he was like oh he's trying
to say again just like an athlete
playing off an injury playing it down
because you don't want
people don't tend to act rationally when
they are panicked yeah
that is for for an example see the
democratic party with corona buyers
and shutting with joe biden can we also
remember the context here so they showed
a clip earlier from february 2nd where
it was like hey you know the virus we're
trying to understand it but we're you
know it doesn't seem to be
you know just like a widespread pandemic
at this point well it wasn't considered
widespread pandemic
in the first week of february this
interview occurred in the second
or third week of march right remember in
the second or third week of march
we had nancy pelosi going down to
chinatown
going everything's fine here come on
down and get the dim sum i mean
yeah like i mean remember what was done
there and all of the information that
we're now with hindsight
understanding for march and february was
all public
what is dim sum it's basically chinese
brunch
oh is it is that like an actual dish no
no no no no it's like
it's like a stock oh there are dim sum
dishes it's like tapas
but chinese and it breaks like the
buffet at heras
similar but less cockroach yeah
could use a sneeze shield though yeah oh
not not that one
we don't believe that's for sure
if you can't get good grip on dumpling
lick your palm
hold on i have to go pet a bat we
actually do do that you know who was
taking out very accurate
your impressions no it's the inherent
racism
uh here is the uh uh clip by the way in
um
what was it this is uh in march donald
trump again for context him talking
about the virus they say we wish
president trump
would give more bad news give badness
i'm not about bad news i want to give
people hope i want to give people
a feeling that we all have a chance i
want to give people
a feeling of hope i could be very
negative i could say wait a minute
those numbers are terrible this is going
to be horrible this is a horrible thing
okay there you go this is him around
that time in march saying the exact same
thing as he was saying to woodward
they're just trying to use the words
play it down and again for context we
should trust the scientists we should
trust the experts so i don't really know
why that matters when this isn't a
scientific issue it's the media trying
to lie to people proactively
here is your favorite got no strings to
hold me down uh marionette
in chief fauci saying there were no lies
uh we're talking about the reality of
what was going on and then when we would
get up in front
of the press conferences which were very
very common after our discussions with
the president
he really didn't say anything different
than we discussed when we were with him
so i i may not be tuned in to the right
thing that they're talking about
but i didn't really see any
discrepancies between what he told
us and what we told him and what he
ultimately came out publicly and said
that man owns no upper lip grow a
mustache
some people require it either watchers
of cuties
or you um
and uh we will get to we do have rand
paul said you want to get to these
points though this is also really
important it's in the same vein of the
fact that
this media accused president trump of
calling the coronavirus a hoax
which he never did he said that the
politicization of the coronavirus being
used against him
was the latest hoax and he was actually
talking about someone a fan
a supporter talking to him here's the
quote in context
kaylee if he's not lying why did he call
it a hoax
oh wait that's a different sorry that
was the wrong one where they called it
sorry that was the one again they're
saying why did he call it a hoax
i apologize and then i have the next
clip it's almost like this is the young
turks here we're like sorry that was the
wrong clip let me explain it to you
because i don't prepare clips
uh that was them last night so this is
an important note they were reiterating
last night
why did he call it a hoax here is the
clip that i initially thought we were
going to
uh it's hard to see through the spit
hood don't put it on your hands corner
black garrett don't do that
just smashing the palm like your test
holiday on the keyboard
get a speaker dishonest people now the
democrats
are politicizing the coronavirus
you know that coronavirus one of my
people came up to me and said mr
president
they tried to beat you on russia russia
russia that didn't work out too well
they couldn't do his supporter was jan
brady tried the impeachment hoax
that was on a perfect conversation
they tried anything they tried it over
and over they've been doing it since she
got in
it's all turning they lost it's all
turning think of it
think of it and this is their new hoax
but you know we did something that's
been pretty amazing we're 15 people in
this massive country
and because of the fact that we went
early we went early
we could have had a lot more than that
and i'm sure people will take that clip
and say oh
way more than 15 people that he was
talking about it already being a
pandemic in europe that had spread and
keep in mind
in that exact same clip again context
this requires this is what changed my
mind is changing my mind is not
uh people always say why don't you do
more debates well we have people on the
show we debate them but change my mind
is not that change of mind is
encouraging you
to rationalize your position let's
rationalize this he said
the impeachment hoax okay did he is he
saying
that the impeachment never happened that
it never existed
no what he is saying is they were trying
to falsely politicize
the issue of impeachment on something
that he didn't do so
by that same token he's not saying the
coronavirus doesn't exist just like the
impeachment
obviously exists he doesn't think it's a
figment of his imagination like joe
biden you know what happened is there
impeachment i pooped
no he is saying that the coronavirus
politicization right now is their new
hoax to say that donald trump didn't
believe it he's actually pointing out
the hoax is that he thinks it's a hoax
right exactly and they're saying that
he's responsible for it and that the
coronavirus is laid squarely at the feet
of donald trump like
it's not the mayor's responsibility in
new york city for doing all the stuff
that they did it's not cuomo's
responsibility it's not anybody else's
responsibility gavin newsom in
california
none of your governors or mayors can
actually do anything for you it's
only the president's responsibility and
that's a hoax that's not true
these guys have their own state
emergency plans for a reason
and they did a bad job enacting those so
maybe go and talk to them
right yeah i don't think that nancy
pelosi thought the coronavirus was a
hoax
no but i think that she was playing it
down when she said
why don't you take me to chinatown
that's what i think and don't forget you
know everything that trump was actually
doing at that time was to try and
protect the american borders
you know put put restrictions one of
those stuff at president um that
apparently don't exist according to some
on the left
but you know what what's ultimately most
hilarious about that is that he was
doing that and they were saying you're
not doing enough but then every example
of a country
where coronavirus has been beat the
curve has been flattened
they shut down the borders right yeah
right and they didn't actually have to
lock down every single place here's i
think here's the problem we're way
behind most other uh western countries
by the way and reopening schools
there's plenty of there's plenty of
countries that we can look to that had
less draconian measures that they
implemented and had
better success with the virus for a
number of reasons but
the reason not tar and feather the good
land of draconia no
or they're good people
no it's terrible no i'm done yeah
i had a thought i don't know i didn't
wait
legally that was a resignation sorry
no i i had a thought i just didn't want
to go on election night
and to fight you go all right all right
i'm done
i think that's the first time i've done
that on can we with the p with the aunt
for the people at the white house trying
this can we double up on spit hoods
because that's not gonna get it no
that's not gonna work
do you have to like cross stitch it i
think if i can arc my morning toppo
chico
look we need to take the lessons from
toilet paper and bring him to spit hoods
one place
is no good
she was the uh unattractive that wasn't
a few hits in the 90s
like
this was a struggle for me this morning
so uh
here's what here's the overlay cutie's
now released on netflix
uh and this is a film that any way you
slice it uh sexually exploits children
you can watch the actual clip and i did
this morning and i felt
so gross uh this is another example of a
chasm
ninety percent on rotten tomatoes versus
six percent
from the and you have people on the left
right now with cuties again when we said
this was a slippery slope they're trying
to say this is actually a film that
explores
the hypersexualization of youth and the
innocence it doesn't matter doesn't
matter i'm sorry
you don't get to explore those topics by
sexually exploiting children yeah
the pedophiles watching are not like oh
it's a comment never doesn't matter
what are they trying to say yeah what is
their scene motivation
along with their overall motivation
creative substitutions that they make no
i think they're thinking
it's hard with the sound dogs and their
pants so it is so
i didn't want to show you guys because i
didn't want it if there happens to be
and out of the millions of people who
watch i'm sure there's
one lone gambler card carrier in there
yeah uh
so i decided to at least try and reflect
just how revolting it is without
breaking the law as the netflix
producers did
and even brendan and bryce will come in
here let's have them come on in
and show you exactly in person um
uh exactly what it is that you guys
would see
on netflix all right guys let's uh start
uh
they're keep in mind picture you have to
use your imagination they are 12 year
old
no sorry eight-year-old girls and let's
hit the beat
uh you guys start twerking
cuties uh all right get it get into a
little bit
what's what's that brendan i don't know
if i'm comfortable doing this
well no this is the whole point yeah
they do it on netflix it's fine even
with the rating system just
you know you you you come by it honestly
look you got it abs
starts working let's hit the beat
imagine you're a seven-year-old girl
jeffrey epstein's what like okay the
point here
is is that they are sexually exploiting
young children we are trying to point
out the moral repugnancy of sexually
exploiting
uh people for views right yeah we're
doing good work
but we're doing that by sexually
exploiting people
for views yes exactly yeah okay but
you're not minors
okay all right well we're even bryce you
can give us a couple
give us some thrust see you brendan
wow that was a six-year-old girl
he's going to keep going this track is
long this is so high
okay well thank you thank you appreciate
that wow
that man batman owns no ass it's like
yoko ono it's just two thighs with a
split
i've never noticed that about yoko ono
by the way
those outfits are far less revealing
than these seven eight nine year old
girls are wearing in cuties you know
what i wanna do because let me read
actually uh for you real quick this is a
review from
uh daily beast where it talks about
people across the political spectrum
have expressed rightful concern about
the streaming giant's choice blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah
in cuties it talks about how she's a
muslim girl in the film it's amazing
girl comes from a muslim household who
then has a bunch of friends who get her
to start twerking and stripping effect
although
they describe it as conservative right
they describe it as that it says
this do corey's film rigorously examines
the ways teen girls mimic the images
they see on social media the ones that
tell them they're about
so you would think oh this is a judgment
this is a condemnation
of them trying to imitate the cardi b's
of the world
nicki minaj's the whoever the latest fit
in the fitness model is selling my fit
tea but no of course listen do you think
that any leftist reporters the people
who give it a 90
rating would judge the current hip-hop
culture which is by and large
african-american and say that's sexual
exploitation
no never what they say is what they see
on social media the ones that tell them
their bodies are all wrong their
presentation's too childish their lives
unremarkable yes
yes so let's have children stripping
reenacting sexual uh
sex acting out sex because of
fat shaming oh my god i think i think
children should be
childish i don't know if that's a crazy
thing
yeah they're innocent and couldn't they
if they were trying to like find a voice
couldn't they have like found an
expression that was
like being a ballerina maybe ballroom
dance finger painting you know
something other than getting on the pole
i mean couldn't we have something like
that
one of the ways that you would have done
this is you go interview the
influencers who are doing it and asking
them
you know you have young fans are you
encouraging i mean this is a very
classic way to investigate people who
are influencing children without
showing the children yeah and exploiting
there's no acceptable
yeah i was so uncomfortable watching
i'll tell you this the two things i
can't really watch are torture porn
and then anything that involves the
sexualization of children i just feel
gross i can't not picture that kid's
parents who
allowed them to take part in this you
know what's really interesting is rather
than showing
you know a successful woman you know
taking care of a business taking him
with family
like honestly cnn is doing right now
showing the first woman ceo of citibank
they're out there showing what you could
do if you want to be a web
yeah yeah well you can't be something if
you don't see it
right i think yeah exactly they've
talked about representation and the
importance of representation in media
yeah exactly so yeah
they know what representation does to
modeling it makes people do stuff how do
they pitch this to the young
kids listen this is going to be if we
want to be clear this is a film
uh about the coming of age of young
women and the sexual
pressures and exploitation that are
forced upon them oh really and how are
you going to do you're going to do that
by judging these influencers and people
who actually thrust these kinds of
sexual pressures upon them
no we're not we're going to take a
different tact but we do think that the
message will be very clear and you will
see it
it will be tastefully done with proper
artistic measures taken so that people
understand this is not about the
sexualization of children but that young
women can be anything they want to be
how do you plan to do that
right and unless by the way that's not
an exaggeration
i'm talking about eight-year-old girls
in cheeky shorts and sports bra is gone
and film critics love it like well this
is this is the kind of messaging we need
so let's see how young women uh what
expectations we have of them
if you run for president and lose you
don't have to offer a concession speech
you can sit in the back room and cry
and if you want a netflix special screw
being carly fiorina and a
ceo of hewlett-packard uh just rub your
nether regions on an re-20.
and then if they were doing some one of
the i saw some of these clips because
people are tweeting about this you know
left and right
they were they were pelvic thrusting
into the floor like there's no other
thing that that could be
right twerking and all that stuff is
horrible and they they then cut to that
and i was like
i didn't know it could get worse it just
got worse i would only allow it if
there's a very
shortcut of a child pelvic thrusting
into the floor and then it results in a
nuclear holocaust
and it ends with the message don't hump
the floor yes
the public service the only way to do it
and even then
you don't create a film by i'm amazed
that it's lit you know what we should do
this french filmmaker the producers at
netflix because they're talking about
how this is about all peace in a muslim
family and traditionalism versus modern
sexuality and the loss of youth
you know what go do an open screening of
this in
iran lebanon egypt take your pick any
muslim
country without security yeah and by the
way by the way book of what the ticket
one way you're not going to return
they're just candidates for child brides
right
that yeah that's that's pretty much well
here's oh no this this is cannes libya
it's a different festival by the way
this is an award winning award-winning
film
this is not just some bee film like
we're gonna comment on right it won
awards for this people stood up and
clapped and said this is more
like what we want they gave her a leg
lamp all right
so you know what's what is very ironic
and even worse about this is that
netflix made a lot of money off the
jeffrey epstein
special a lot of people watched it yeah
it was a very good indictment of the
system and the people that protected him
and especially everything bad that was
happening and how these women were
groomed and how their sense of identity
was compromised at the young age of 13.
right and now we've got eight-year-olds
that you're saying you're you're doing
the exact same part of it
um i mean i would be surprised if glenn
maxwell has a freaking executive
producer credit on cuba's i was going to
say i
thought it was in poor taste that uh
that epstein had an associate producing
credit uh
um listen we are morning we have to get
going i believe we have rand paul
on the show uh so i believe he's uh he's
waiting for us we are going to go to the
latest installment of white privilege
boys
for you guys first and then talk about
the recent close call that he had
along with some of the democrat
politicians who are taking their own
private security measures
uh while encouraging the defunding of
police for you rand paul
right up after this break
and now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
ah hey there boys good to see you again
what can i do you for thanks mr
macarthur
well you can start by giving us
everything in the cash register well
golly is that a firearm you're pointing
at me there
yeah yeah you knew it i'm very
disappointed in you boys we don't care
empty it out yeah yeah
get out man oh i suppose boys will be
boys i'm going to have to call the
sheriff you know but
you've got me for now go ahead take
everything thanks mr mcarthur thanks
pistol whip him
oh all right now that's one for you
that's one for you go ahead take some
bazooka joe and get out of here you
rascals oh those boys what pickle will
they find themselves in
next stay tuned for next week's
installment of
adventures of the white privilege boys
black rifle cafe
no sir it's actually just how it was in
the prompter it's it's coffee
okay co-favoring
okay folks frankly it's the best coffee
out there ar15 coffee m16
coffee it's a coffee with bazooka
bazooka joe the coffee look at the bread
can we get the hero shot
did they still make bazooka joe it used
to be a petty
rifle of color coffee this coffee should
be dating a kardashian
right this coffee is the best coffee
black
rifle coffee and unlike other companies
who claim
small batch or premium black rifle
coffee isn't roasted
frankly until you place your order
making sure it's the freshest coffee
many people don't know it's it's a bead
it goes bad coffee go to
blackriflecoffee.com
slash crowder enter the promo code
crowder to receive
20 off your first order of black rifle
coffee
yeah i think that's the best we're gonna
get uh thank you okay
great somebody give me a diet coke
all right very glad to have our next
guest he's been on the show quite a few
times and it's been tough to get guests
because we're we're
broadcasting all the time live in the
morning
uh you know we love him he's a senator
that's what he is he's an actual center
we always talk about trusting the
experts don't trust this show though do
go to blackriflecoffee.com
20 off uh senator rand paul thank you
for being on the show sir
glad to be with you all i was told it
was dangerous after your fourth cup of
coffee that's not your fourth cup of
coffee is it
no it's my fifth and it has a it has an
adverse reaction where it
buzzes and then it mellows me out um and
then you have to go to the bathroom
yes so where i use cocaine so
i'm joking i know he's a senator he was
on our show someone used cocaine
um senator rand paul i almost said mr i
missed
i apologize senator paul i almost said
mr rand paul
yeah mr senator is fine okay
we'll go with a doctor you obviously
people know that you recently
uh had a run-in after um you spoke at
the rnc a few weeks ago
and uh this is when they were trump's
nomination happened can you explain for
people who may not be familiar i think
everyone is
what happened afterward when you were
what i saw was being mobbed and we have
some b-roll here
yeah the uh interesting thing about it
was that uh you see some people
commenting online oh he must have wanted
attention and
why would he be there and why you know
why was he
in the middle of this mob well we were
leaving the white house
and our hotel was right across the
street from the exit
right we got to the exit though and we
could see them all
and we could see them chasing people
down sort of like
you know a hair darts out and a pack of
wolves chases them that's what the mob
was so we didn't leave
yeah the sec the secret service said you
should take the bus with the police
escort so we did
it took about 45 minutes but it took us
farther away from our hotel
so we had to eventually come back
towards where the mob was
and so we got an uber like a normal
human
i'm just like any other human i get in
an uber or a lyft i don't have
always a fancy limousine or 10 security
guards you take your lift to the
radisson we get it
so we got in an uber we tried to get
there but the police wouldn't let us go
down the last two blocks
we pleaded with them and it really was a
mistake on their part
not to let us drive because it was
unsafe to be on the street
which my wife continues to remind me it
was a mistake to get out of the car
we only had two blocks and we could see
at the end of the first block some
policemen that's about 100 yards
we began walking much to the chagrin of
my wife and the other two ladies who
didn't really want to get out of the car
i said we can make it it's not that far
um you know those were the the last bit
of good advice i was able to give
so we got about halfway there there were
small groups passing us
and when people say oh he was heckled
well that's what the small groups did
they
jeered at us and heckled and if that's
all that happened we would have never
said a thing
people yelled at us hey you know
whatever and we crossed to the other
side of the street and we avoided them
and that was not a big deal
but as we got within about 20 yards of a
police car with two or three policemen
standing there and some police
motorcycles i think
right as we saw them we were headed
towards them we're about 20 yards away
a big crowd came around the corner
chanting and marching
probably 30 people in the crowd they
spotted me just to be clear
oh wait a second what was that just to
be clear uh that is a crowd
30 people is a crowd three's company
30 is a crowd yeah uh 30
came towards us and then at some point
someone said it's rand paul we've got
rand paul we've got him trapped
but then 30 became 60 became 90
became over 100 people they came from
every sewer in every direction
they surrounded us and these were
vile screaming hateful people
that were basically completely
surrounding us with no space between us
and them
there were people throwing fluid on us
that we had no idea what it was
there were people you know saying things
and
uh using uh terms to you know call my
wife and this and that it was a terrible
situation
even with us standing next to the
policemen i wasn't sure that they we
would not be overwhelmed by the size of
the crowd and the policeman
i don't think the policeman knew who i
was either so i leaned over to him and
said
they know who i am i'm in congress you
need to call for
for uh reinforcements so he calls into
his headset i can't hear what he says
but we're still there for probably 15
minutes with the crowd becoming more and
more menacing
at some point a few more policemen show
up and they have bikes
and they use the bikes and their bodies
to serve as sort of a barricade a human
barricade
to try to walk slowly and this crowd
sort of keeps pressing in
so they had no fear they knew these were
uh uniformed officers because you hear a
lot of complaints
these are uniformed officers no they
they knew they were cops and didn't care
anyway
they just wanted to hit you that they
were uniform they all had bulletproof
vests on
right and so as we're making our way at
one point one of the cops gets shoved
through his bicycle
about falls over backwards and i was
able to grab the back of his
uh bulletproof vests and stabilize him
and said look
i'm behind you if you need help i don't
know how much help i was going to be but
i was offering to be helpful
if i could at that point you're just an
extension of his bulletproof vest
you act as extra security it's like
putting up a
it's like putting up you know just one
of those ballistic testing gels
in front of the bulletproof vest so
you'll offer them some more protection
but i did want to ask you one thing
because you just said
they knew who you were i would argue
they know you're they know that you're
famous
they didn't know who you were because
they were chanting say her name
say her name these people don't even
know that you
uh were the one who who authored the
brianna justice for brianna taylor uh
bill
can you explain that to people i was
amazed that they picked you of all folks
yeah there's a certain irony to being
threatened with violence by people
saying say her name
when i've actually met with the family
and i've also introduced legislation the
briona taylor act gets rid of no knock
raids
right i've never i've just never been a
fan of no knock raids i think going in
in the middle of the night for marijuana
or some drugs
it's a threat to the police officers who
often get shot
but also inside people get shot and i
think of it from my own personal
perspective if someone comes in my house
after 10 o'clock
i'm not asking a lot of questions and
i'm probably shooting you know because
nobody's about nobody can come you're
just not used to someone coming in your
house after not
you know this is after midnight and this
is barney frank and it's your basement
but yes
but anyway so uh they're chanting this
and not one of them has any idea of
introduces legislation
but here's the the gist of it black
lives matter
uh the the woman who's in charge of it
in louisville was asked about this
and she said yes we could see fear in
their eyes
but we want them to live in fear we have
to live in fear
so they should so the goal is not
changing legislation
the goal is terrorizing uh public
officials
and the thing is is every damn one of
them needs to be arrested as far as i'm
concerned
disorderly conduct preventing someone
from going somewhere
going in a private restaurant throwing
people's food on the floor surrounding
people in a restaurant
it's all invasion of a private space or
it's publicly
disorderly conduct but here's what
happened one of the policemen that was
defending us
a few minutes later was punched in the
face and got stitches above his eye
do you know what the dc court system did
with the assaulter
released on his own recognizance yeah
and so i tweeted out after
we found out he'd been assaulted and
they released him i tweeted if you're
looking for him try
kenosha because these people
took the midnight train to kenosha we're
seeing these people
some of the same faces are in portland
kenosha
dc louisville how are they getting there
they're staying at the w hotel the
willard hotel the willard hotel might be
500 to a thousand dollars a night
who's paying for them to stay in the
willard hotel who's who's paying for
them to have
air flight who's paying them to do this
and here's the sad truth of it
it's probably not going to be a sinister
name like george soros
it's going to be corporate america yeah
corporate america is giving money to
black lives matter
and my guess is if we follow the money
the people who paid for the plane
tickets and the hotels and the people
continue to do this
is black lives matter yeah but people
should not be giving money to a group
that is then funding thuggery if you
want to if you're in favor of trying to
support african americans and success
and all this
for the community give it to the united
negro college fund give it to the naacp
but giving money to black lives matter
is giving money to promote thuggery and
violence
and arson and all these things happening
in our cities
and america ought to be ashamed of
themselves let me i have three questions
for you
and i know that you're a busy man i i
did a change of mind on this do you
believe that black lives matter
knowing what we've just discussed should
be classified or at least gets close to
being a domestic terrorist organization
i think people should be i don't know
what that it means to tell you too but i
think people need to see what they're
for they're for getting rid of the
nuclear family they're for
socialism therefore transforming they
think america is a rotten place and
ought to be a completely different place
based on a socialist or marxist model
yeah so people need to be
aware of that and i think just calling
them a terrorist organization
you know that it might help but i think
really what happened well i mean
treating them as such
i mean treating them in the sense of
keeping an eye on them and being aware
of their because like you're saying you
know listen if there are sleeper cells
that people discuss
we always are following the money trail
we're going how did this per we have
receipts what flight did this person get
on but we don't have any answers
and like you said it has been documented
that these people been found in multiple
cities and what they stand for
but we really don't have a way of
tracking what seems to be
systemically organized crime within the
organization that's my concern
i think there definitely is an aspect of
that the danger calling the whole group
terrorists is there probably elements of
it who are peaceful protesters
arguing for speech and so i hate to say
that we're going to completely eliminate
this
see in a marketplace of ideas i would
rather that we announce
and me i have a voice on television
begin to tell corporate america you're
making a big mistake
so i i know a gentleman in my town who
is uh works in pharmaceutical sales for
like a big pharmaceutical company
uh if he donates to black lives matter
they're doubling and tripling his
donation it is a preferred
and it is a supported donation with this
large pharmaceutical company
they need to be told that they're
supporting thuggery and that at least an
aspect of black lives matter are
thugs that are inciting riots and that
are
preaching that we should have our public
officials live in fear
sure and to be tormented if that's a
corporate america needs to
to stop and defund them instead of
defunding the police
corporate america needs to defund black
lives matter yeah i agree
and i want to be clear i delineate
between the sentiment the idea of the
movement that black lives matter all
lives matter black lives matter justice
the idea
that non-violent drug offenders should
not be held
in prison or held longer than their
sentence like we see with kamala harris
and donald trump has done a lot for
criminal justice reform
black lives matter the sentiment is
different from the organization
i have two questions for you i know
gerald wanted one but we'll have to get
you in later
do you think that there's going to be
more unrest if uh
or what do you expect if president trump
wins reelection we just went through a
bunch of articles here posted at daily
beast and
these plans to occupy the white house
lawn or in front of the lawn
them talking about hillary clinton
saying that joe biden should not concede
under any circumstance
that's concerning what do you see
happening if donald trump wins
reelection
i think i'm not i'm not positive but
what i would say
is i think there is more unrest in our
cities if you do not arrest the
perpetrators if people can throw rocks
at the police and not be arrested if you
can punch a policeman and not be
arrested if you can throw a molotov
cocktail
if you can set a fire and not be
arrested that's what happens so you have
to have
some ability to arrest the lesser crimes
for a reasonable amount of punishment
but you have to do that
with regard to the election i think it's
really the philosophy of the two
candidates
joe biden says oh i'm not for defunding
the police but i'm for reallocating the
money to other places
that sounds to me like defunding the
police joe biden has not spoken out
neither is kamala harris have not spoken
out and said the violence against my
wife and i was wrong
they're saying oh setting fire and and
you know burning the courthouse is wrong
but they're not rebuking black lives
matter for the tactic
of assaulting and confronting and
terrorizing basically
uh public officials not one word and
i've called him out and asked joe biden
now come on
to say something about it not a peep so
yes i think there'll be more violence
and there will be a reaction if
if trump wins but in some ways in the
long term
the only way you get less violence in
our cities is you got to get rid of the
people who run the cities and for 50
years
democrats have run all of our major
cities the top 10 cities with a top 10
murder rate
all are run by democrats and have been
for 50 years
so what we need to do and what needs to
happen to the good people who live like
on the south side of chicago
and are plagued by this violence and
have their little kids shot and drive
drive-by shootings
they need to be told democrats don't
give a crap about your young black kids
who are being shot
democrats have run your city and allow
this violence and if you want to get rid
of violence in your city
vote for a republican we have we have we
have lots of
african-american republican candidates
the the woman running in
um in baltimore the young man running
against maxine waters we have some good
candidates out there
who are african-american but care about
the community enough to want to stop
the violence yeah i and you know what i
think that this is a perfect example you
at this point in time um
mr rand paul doctor that uh uh dr mr
senator mr congress
um of reasonable libertarian of what
libertarianism actually is because both
you and president trump okay
uh probably you're very anti-war in
general president trump is one of the
most anti-war presidents that i can
remember in modern history
you're anti-arresting people for drug
offenses you're remarkably consistent
you wrote the brianna taylor act if
people know your stance on no knock
warrants
but you are libertarian but you also
understand the legitimate role of
government right now of the police force
so you can be a libertarian
be against foreign wars that are
unnecessary and also say you know what
we don't defund our police and we make
sure that people breaking the law are
punished because that is much more
consistent than
governor whitmer obviously wants to
defund the police she just upgraded her
security by 1.1 million dollars
and an eight-foot electrified fence
because fences and walls work
chicago mayor lori lightfoot supported
the protest defunding police she's
upping her security
mayor andrew kinther of columbus uh his
uh his security is being up to ted
wheeler of portland once they tried to
burn down his condo all of a sudden
he's just it's just a dust cloud of
mayor ted wheeler from where he used to
be
and he's in a different county do you
think that's important right now as kind
of a representative uh the baton holder
right now of the
sort of libertarian movement that
explaining to people
a legitimate role of government like a
police force that can protect its
citizens
is not socialism no and i think it is
important for libertarians because some
libertarians online have been
criticizing me for wanting to go after
some of these violent people in the
cities
right but here's the thing the true
libertarian is against
indiscriminate searching of financial
records and phone records the idea of
warrantless searches but libertarians if
they're thoughtful libertarians are not
against using probable cause
and the fourth amendment if you assault
a police officer
you've got probable cause of that you
can go to a judge and say
the person who assaulted the police
officers should we look at their visa
bill
and their hotel bill and find out who's
financing their behavior
without question that is completely
libertarian to be for law enforcement
what would be not libertarian would be
to say we're going to search the
financial records of all people uh who
we do facial recognition of who are
marching in a protest
that would be terrible and i'd be
absolutely opposed to that because
i've been part of protest from the tea
party movement i don't want
indiscriminate searching
but someone who commits a crime yes you
look at their financial records you have
probable cause to and you get permission
from a judge
for that person right we don't do
widespread searches
and one other thing on the gun issue you
mentioned all these people having
security
think of mike bloomberg he's
spent more money trying to erode and
destroy the second amendment than
anybody in the whole country
and yet he has armed guards and so in
the mike bloomberg world poor people
wouldn't get protection
rich people would and they'd buy their
protection and that is the hypocrisy of
these people and these political leaders
who do have armed security guards do you
think de blasio's got armed security
guards
they hate guns for the ordinary people
but they're happy to protect themselves
yeah and it's not just about hypocrisy
like hey look you're being a hypocrite
it's about the fact that they're
systemically putting other americans at
risk
risk often the most vulnerable minority
communities where over 80 percent of
black americans support at least
as much if not more of a police presence
than they have now
while they upgrade all their own
personal security i know you must go
dr rand paul i really appreciate you
taking the time and
i think you're a great ambassador for
what libertarianism is in 2020 i
appreciate it
thank you no more coffee today for you
then i'll do my best
thank you sir just colombian gold nose
candy
booger sugar uh he's gone right yeah
all right you guys enjoy sorry you had a
question no no it was long actually just
make it into a comment
i was gonna say you know hey i know that
this studies just come out that 93
of the protests have been peaceful in
that moment did you care that maybe 93
of the night had been peaceful up until
then right matter to you that that 93
was good you lived in the seven yeah so
let's just say you're about to go give a
speech
okay in an auditorium yeah that seats
exactly 100 people
and they say 93 of them don't have guns
yeah
go seven of them would like to kill you
yeah but that's only seven percent
yeah that's why these people don't
that's why there's no consistency on the
left because right now they feel like
we're part of the 93 and we hate another
percentage once you're a part
of that small percentage who the other
majority or
minority of americans want to harm and
you realize that they're getting off
scot-free
that guy punched a cop yeah the guy was
going after think about that punched a
cop to the point that he needed stitches
these guys i wonder if these police
right now they're at the right if
there's like hockey players where
they're not even going to replace their
teeth they're just going to put a mouth
guard in and clear up the scar tissue
after they're done with their after
they're done with their whole career
that's what they do in hockey because
they're going to lose it again like i'm
going to replace the tooth
i do after i've joined 50 50 club
you know it was it was something that
you know maybe you can see where the
protester was coming from right i mean
look left hook that officer was
protecting
senator rand paul who was out there
trying to get rid of no knock warrants
uh he's definitely the guy that we want
to go out it was a right-wing protest
actually so
that's what it was yeah he's a little
rand paul like i like he said like he's
ba
he basically at that point is like an
additional helmet
i feel like yeah he's not gonna help out
like he was on that cop like cartoon
cats
yeah extra storage exactly you know the
guy who met with brianna taylor's family
right you know terrible
i'm surprised we haven't seen an article
that was like rand paul comes to be
white savior
talks to victim's family he tries to get
justice we don't need you
whitey yeah that's literally anything
that he does
blm is is twists the entire opposite way
if they're not out there trying to
assault him his wife and the officers
who are protecting
i think that if you just got these blank
lines matter i mean assuming there was
a rational molecule in their body which
listen
i stretch but the point is i bet if you
were to get someone who could think
critically who is on board with the idea
of black lives matter and police
brutality and having you know limited
government
intrusion if you could get them copies
of reason magazine
from uh the 90s 80s whenever started
through now they would find
more articles on police brutality or
police reform in the libertarian
publication than they had ever seen in
their lives they would say
these people are right-wing [ __ ]
they look like they actually it's the
rand paul's of the world i bet it's like
cigar aficionado with michael jordan i
bet you they
had more cover models than the pauls
in libertarian weekly yeah well you made
a great point too asking him about uh
making black lives matter you know
declaring them maybe a terrorist group
or something like that for domestic
terrorism and i think you're right like
they knew they do need to be declared
what they are right i don't care if 93
of them are peaceful this is not like
peaceful marches with martin luther king
and the fbi was just trying to look into
him or something like that these are
people that are going out and rioting
and threatening people and committing
violent acts by the way the guy that
punched the cop
what do you think he's going to do next
time he's like well i punched a guy last
time got away with it i got away with it
he's either going to do the exact same
thing or maybe up the ante a little bit
that's why you don't play games kissing
on the rug
exactly which by the way joe lewis
doesn't do you don't do that do you join
oh that's great
oh look again right joe lewis it's the
fire
are you awake are you alive he is there
you go oh there he is okay thank you
thank you he's going back i was worried
i do that with my son i'm like are you
breathing thank you gentlemen i
appreciate it you guys have to sit there
but i'm gonna have to hit my clothes
here
for next week let me know again find the
secret word that is available uh on the
audio only podcast uh if you're not
subscribed on itunes uh it's not itunes
anymore it's apple android
next week tuesday night we're going to
be live streaming the town hall
um let me wrap this up and talk about uh
fat pride so
uh not just fat pride but let me
sometimes people say i've gotten some
flack lately where people say
hey you can be harsh and let me explain
to you
why i'm harsh or why rand paul sometimes
can be harsh and why the right wing why
conservatives can be seen as harsh and
often we see that with parenting i'll
use my example with
with that pride i don't have a problem
just like with black lives matter i
don't have a problem with people saying
hey we need to make sure that we value
black lives i believe that all lives
should be valued and i'm not saying
all lives matter i'm not saying it
confrontationally i am saying
yes i agree if uh we were at a point
right now where black lives were not as
valued in our legal system
our current currently established legal
system is white lives yeah we need to
fix that
and i would be right there with you when
that was the case before the 1960s so
i'm not saying it to be a little piss
and i'm saying all lives matter
including black lives i'm on board with
you
same thing here i don't have a problem
with people who are fat
um i don't have a problem with people
who support black lives i have a problem
with black lives matter the organization
i have a problem with the fat
pride movement and if it comes across as
harsh let me explain to you why when i
see a fat person
at the gym or jogging i just saw this
this morning and you guys know i'm up
early
i'm up early like at four or something
every now and then i think of just
sending a tweet to jocko
because every morning i would beat him
but i don't care that people know that
i'm up at 4 15.
so um i saw a very overweight person
jogging this morning and it was dark was
before the sun was out
and it almost brought it honestly
sometimes it almost brings a tear to my
i wanted to
i wanted a hug having been that chubby
little kid i wanted to hug him and say
this is this is great listen it's going
to suck
this is terrible but keep going you're
going to get there it it
brings me to tears if i see someone who
is overweight who's struggling who
clearly is not someone
who has chosen the gym as a hobby you
know what doesn't impress me
people in yoga pants who love doing
physical activities
anyway it's not hard i'm one of those
people my activity
would be a bag of flamin hot cheetos
while binge watching something on
netflix not cuties
so the people who take those steps who
make that effort
despite the fact that it's not their
natural inclination are the ones that
really
touch me and why why am i so why am i
harsh when i say hey look you shouldn't
be telling people
who are 400 pounds test holiday or
anyone out there or
black lives matter use them as an
analogy here but you shouldn't be
telling people
that it's okay and they shouldn't feel
ashamed for things that are bad for
their health
you shouldn't tell people that hey it's
okay you shouldn't be ashamed
of the fact that you moused off to a cop
that could be hazardous to your health
having a blood type pudding having a
cholesterol that can't be measured on a
chart they have to get one of those
abacuses at a child doctor's room
that's not good for your health and you
know what else you actually
it comes from love being harsh because
anyone here who's ever accomplished
anything you can take audio weight with
guitar you can take
quarter black garrett with also music
what he's done with all these crafts and
these
the makeup and the the artifacts that he
can make like the art of the
ark of the covenant you guys don't know
i can't look in the green room without
my face melting we have to keep that
door closed
you can't gerald was his wife his bill
with his law
me with what you see here whatever it is
that you have worked hard to achieve
that is
the greatest feeling in the world
because it can't be cheated
that feeling of accomplishment of
overcoming of of
of insurmountable seemingly
insurmountable obstacles
being overcome and knowing that you did
it
through putting in the work when no one
expected you to is the kind of
feeling that cannot be faked just like
getting an a
on a test for a kid gives them a kind of
feeling that you can't fake by not
using a red marker just like a kid
scoring the winning soccer kick i don't
know if they're called goals or ball and
net i'm straight
but just like the kid winning the soccer
game
you don't give them the same feeling by
saying you know what we're going to even
out the score
so that everybody feels good and so when
you just excuse
behavior that you know is detrimental to
people's
not only their lives their livelihoods
their well-being and then turn around
and talk about mental health well guess
what
the best thing that someone can do for
their mental health
is getting really really good at
something or accomplishing something
and i just see it as unempathetic
i see it as sociopathic to try and rob
people whether it's a minority whether
it's uh discriminated against gender
sex take your pick today or a fat person
because you
want to white knight really for no one
else but for yourself to feel good about
telling somebody to be complacent
so i want you folks out there to take
inventory of folks in your lives
and maybe some people who you've thought
are hard asses like i've had this in my
life have had it with my dad when i grew
up and why is he so hard i realized that
it's because he loved me most
he expected the most of me and he was
accomplished
in what he did and he knew that it was a
feeling that couldn't be fake so people
who are out there
i want you to think take take a second
think of someone who maybe you sort of
mislabeled for a while
as someone who you thought was an ass
and ask yourself were they actually just
harsh
were they actually just rough around the
edges because they cared
sometimes caring can come across
as mean even though that's not the
intent
and i want you to think of that person
once you think of them reach out
and thank them and then think about what
it is that they
they were being mean about that maybe
you weren't comfortable dealing with
and go and deal with it because we've
all had it in our honest quiet moments
guess what the cnns the black lives
matter the test holidays the instagrams
the
the dove body pride that all goes goes
away
and you have to face yourself
and the truth is a feeling that can't be
faked you either know that you've
accomplished something
or you didn't and i will tell you this
as someone growing up who believed some
lies lies
are not compassionate don't pass it
along pass along harshness if you have
to in truth alright we'll see you next
week have a huge stream
on tuesday it says livestream
subject for today
toys
unicorns
unique
in the unicorns in the universe
like sleeping